yeah thank you for thank you for the
invitation
it's my great pleasure to be
participating in this great workshop
today my talk is about an example of a
very interesting phenomenon happening in
a lot of non convex optimization
algorithms and this is joint work with
tormach Eisen one from Princeton or fear
and jujitsu from Carnegie Mellon so non
compos estimation problems really are
permeate almost all fields of science
and engineering so there's a lot of
variety of applications ranging from HS
completion deconvolution to even deep
learning if you look at the empirical
risk function or the negative log
likelihood function that you are
interested usually these functions are
highly non-congress so this gives rise
to a lot of challenges when we try to
solve problems of this kind in
particular non conversa T will result in
a lot of computational issues there so
the good thing is that not all of the
non convex problems are equally
difficult for many of the cases if we
are able to explore certain statistical
models underlying the problems we have
actually we might actually see some news
that's much better than we thought for
example we might be seeing some benign
landscape for many of the problems we
are interesting and as and this actually
gives us a lot of hope in designing
efficient algorithms that can as long as
we are able to exploit the statistical
properties or the geometry in an
appropriate so this talk is basically
about how we can use the Cisco bottles
to help us understand the non compos
optimization algorithms so the goal here
is about a fast non commerce
optimization algorithms so typically if
you want to have a fast algorithm and
this is a typical paradigm that people
have been using for example the first
stage so this is a two-stage algorithm
the first stage we try to use some
method to find an initial point within
the socco basin of attraction
and the next step is that we try to run
some iterative procedures and yogic
convergence as long as you are careful
enough and you might be able to get the
desired solution and very quickly okay
however this since this is a non convex
problem typically even if you are
looking at a local region surrounding
the global solution the landscape
actually is also much more volatile than
we thought and in fact there's a lot
more fluctuation compared to the
standard like quadratic function so
actually we need to be very careful even
we are within the local region and this
is one of the motivation for a lot of
prior work and all of these problems so
in prior work typically certain kind of
regularization is recommended in order
to either to stabilize or regularize the
search direction so that even within
this local region we can actually
converge fast and let me just give you
some examples for example for the face
retrieval problems people have been
suggesting that we can use some sort of
truncation or trimming procedure to help
accelerate the gradient descent for
matrix completion for blind
deconvolution for these problems
actually starting from Andrea and it has
been suggested that maybe we can rather
than running the optimization based on
the original loss function maybe we can
actually look here some regular
eyes-closed function by adding some
penalty terms there and to help us get
to a more stable trajectory of the
gradient descent algorithm all the other
way is to enforce some sort of
projection to help us with this okay so
there's already a lot of theory about
regularized version of the optimization
algorithms but in comparison the
unregular i's version of the the
gradient methods are much much less
understood for example take a matrix
completion and blind the convolution for
example there's almost no theory talking
about unregular i's version of the
gradient methods and the situation for
face retrieval is slightly
better so we have result for an dragon
but the computational cost there is
highly suboptimal compared to the
regular regular rice version is much say
okay so I don't know actually maybe
there is some theory but all of the
theory based on the regularized version
of the cost function or some some sort
of extra life for example like in in
Jason's paper about this global geometry
thing and they are changing the the the
empirical loss function to be some
regularize version in order to case say
something about the gradient okay baby
I'm too extreme but as far as I know yes
sir your for matrix sensing days there
is a way to do this I think just for
matches completion not just usually if
you look at more general version of
matrix factorization problem let's say
and there is a way to do this yeah is
there something just say for majors
completion things are
earlier everybody get this amen sorry no
no no no I mean the Reg arised version
is suggested by Andrea first so I mean a
lot of lot of people follow this one
actually so yeah anyway so okay so yep
okay so now the question is really there
about whether we can use on our
regularized version of gradient descent
to achieve at least the same
computational complexity as as similar
to the rigorous version so in this talk
I'm unable to present the ground theory
about this so let me just use a face
retrieval as a guiding threat to present
all of the ideas here and all of these
ideas actually carry out to which is
completion and blending convolution okay
so okay what's a bit so first of all
usually these regularization methods are
highly tight so so it's very much
tailored to the very specific
statistical models here so practically
usually if you run these things usually
there's an almost no role of this
regularization PI even it's for example
lining and Andrea's non-congress
manifold gradient descent method that he
used if you run a really actually these
regularization has never been used in
practice actually so they are enforcing
some extra term so if something lies
your trajectory go out of some comfort
zone and you will this will be effective
but practical they actually this is not
really something that has ever been
effective so I think a good
understanding about the unrealized
version could be could be more us could
say something that's more practical
so so let me focus on faced with tribal
and then explain all of the ideas here
the problem is the following so so
suppose I have a ground true X which is
an dimensional and then I observe a lot
of quadratic equations about the unknown
object so let's say I have M of them and
the goal is to recover extract from this
from this quadratic system of equations
okay and starting with a so there has
already a lot of work on this this
problem and talking from 2014 Immanuel
Sheldonian Mattia has proposed so-called
what Ingo flow for solving this problem
and they look at this empirical loss
objective functions so this is sort of
like a mean square error for the problem
and then we followed a they follow a
two-stage approach firstly the use
spectral method to obtain initialization
after that they use something called
working a gradient iterations are and
Ronnie until convergence if you focus on
the real case essentially this is like a
vanilla gradient descent method so and
there has already been some Theory
obtained by Emanuel Sheldon Ahmadi so my
goal is to tries to first examine what
they have are using some standard
optimization theory and then try to see
whether this is already catch
magistratus or not okay so since this is
a vanilla gradient descent method that
is locally so let's try to look at what
gradient optimization people can tell us
about this this problem usually if we
want to say something converges fast
there are usually two standard
conditions they are determined that
linear convergence of a gradient descent
algorithm so one it's a strong capacity
at least in the restricted sense
another is smoothness and also maybe in
the restricted sense also it is well
known that if we just run a gradient
descent for such a nice function which
is alpha strongly convex and beta
smooth and we have l2 error contraction
there and the error the the contraction
rate is essentially just determined by
beta over alpha which is the condition
number so essentially if we can always
make sure that with the iterates are
always within a nice region and then we
can say that this algorithm can attain a
epsilon accuracy within roughly a beta
of over alpha times some logarithmic
factor the number of iterations so this
is what gradient descent theory can tell
us ok so now let's try to apply this
theory to the face retrieval problem and
see what this can tell us so let's again
look at some random model so suppose
that we have a Gaussian design a each of
the sampling vector is iid Gaussian
let's start with the simplest case let's
say we have infinite sample so so it
becomes a nice becomes a very nice
landscape in fact if you look at the
Hessian the expected Hessian in the
local region and you can prove that this
is actually a very very well conditioned
function locally and it's also strongly
convex and as a result if you look at
the infinite sample case the working of
flow actually converges to the truth
within logarithmic iterations now the
issue arises when we move on to the more
realistic situation where we have finite
number of samples so when number of
samples you have is just slightly above
the information limits now the function
the Hessian with high probability the
Hessian stos tronic converse function at
is locally now the issue is there the
condition number is extremely bad at
least for this this Gaussian design
model the condition number and this
regime can be as large as n and it's the
number of unknowns we have so this is
not a good news because this is
essentially saying that the number of
iterations taken to converge my actually
depends on the problem size
in fact just applying this theory we can
say that what Inga flow attends epsilon
accuracy within roughly n iterations and
this is exactly the theory presented by
Candy's and his co-authors so the
question now is of course that now we
need n iterations to converge this seems
to be very slow so whether we have a way
to accelerate it and the answer
difference is yes and so you can use
some sort of regular ice gradient
regularized version of the gradient
descent to achieve much faster
convergence but this is not the focus of
this talk and the focus about whether
this theory really are matches what's
happening in practice which is the
theory that's basically based on the
generic optimization of theory so let's
take a closer inspection of this problem
and see what's happening so waiting the
flow we say that it's slow because it
converges roughly within n iterations
and the reason that you converges within
any iteration is that the step size it's
going to be very small so so we take the
step size according to the smoothness
parameter in this case is 1 over ends
it's a vanishingly small step size and
this choice this step size choice
essentially just suggested by generic
optimization theory all put another way
this is sort of like justify the worst
case optimization theory and the
question is whether this kind of
optimization Theory really capture
what's going on at least in this in this
problem so in order to answer this
question so let me first collect some
numerical evidence and essence
illustration so let's look at this
runner what Ingo flow and for a
different problem sizes ranging from 20
to 1,000 and let's fix the step size to
be 0.1 rather than taking to be 1 over N
but it seems therefore all of the cases
actually the the algorithm Astrakhan
which is very fast for most of the cases
actually within 200 iterations you
always get like five digit accuracy or
something so it seems that even the
vanilla version of gradient descent
actually works could be could work a
much more aggressively than there was
suggested by by the Working Girl flow
theory so now the question is why is why
this efficiency is unexplained by the
existing theory okay so in order to
answer this question so let's take a
closer look on the gradient descent
theory and see what goes wrong here okay
so as we mentioned we would like to make
sure that our iterates are within a nice
region and this isn't region that has
sort of like restricted strong capacity
and smoothness and if we look at the
face retrieval problem this region is
characterized by the following
conditions first of all the point should
not be too far away from the the ground
truth so look at the finger fire as l2
ball surrounding the solution
next thing is probably even more
important is that actually we also want
to make sure that X the point X is not
going to be too aligned with any of the
sampling vectors so in some sense this
is saying that it needs to be in
coherent with the sampling back to for
example if we look at the region of
points where with that is incoherent
with respect to the first sampling
vector and then you get this strip if
you have another sampling vector
essentially and this will give you a
Polito so eventually the region that
enjoy nice and geometry it's going to be
something like a polytope rather than
rather than just an elgible
so now we can see what goes wrong in the
in the existing theory so in the prior
theory it basically says that you feel
if the region that you have is it's an
l2 ball and because we can make sure
that a 0 2 contraction there so after a
few iterations actually we can all we
have l2 contractions so we always stay
within this nice region eventually and
this can converge but if the nice region
that we have is like a polytope name
then the thing some some bad issues
happen for example if you start with
within the this poly tope and if you run
it for one gradient iteration you can
make sure that we have a true
contraction but you have no way to make
sure that this will still stay within
the poly tope of inches and as long as
you jump out of this poly tope and then
the gradient method may actually
overshoot and if you overshoot
eventually and this will dis will
diverge so essentially most of the
almost all of the prior work have been
suggesting some regularization method in
order to make sure that the iterates are
always within the nice region and the
finding of this work is it's the
following so even though the generic
optimization Theory cannot say make sure
that we are within this region and using
some statistical tools if you look at
the probability probabilistic model in a
more careful way we can actually make
sure that the good the iterates will
always stay within this nice region
throughout the execution of the entire
algorithm ok so this becomes a nice
thing because if you are always staying
within this poly tope and we can make
sure that the algorithm will never jump
out of it and so you will not overshoot
and as a result and this gives us a very
good contraction properties ok so the
key message
here is the gradient descent even the
vanilla version can implicitly force all
of the iterates to stay within an in
coherence region and which is the key
thing that make that enable fast
convergence of the gradient descent
methods so more formally the the theorem
is try the following so we can make sure
you're on the ID Gaussian design the
working of flow will always satisfy the
interest will always satisfy the in some
sort of in coherence condition and with
this and we can obtain a very fast
convergence so essentially it converges
within logarithmic iterations even when
the sample size is not much larger than
the information theoretic limits so we
are able to adopt a much more aggressive
step size and we have a computational
complexity that's much better than the
existing theory just maybe one minute
explaining the key idea about showing
all of this since our goal is to say
that the iterates will always stay in
coherent with any each of the the
sampling vector so essentially this is
sort of like a point wise in our
infinity non bound so to do this I'm
going to introduce some auxiliary
sequence let's call your --xtl and this
is constructed by dropping out a single
sample from all of the the measurements
we have so suppose I am dropping their
arrows measurements I'm not going to use
it but I run the same algorithm on this
new set of samples so why this is
interesting because if you drop one
sample so the iterate has never seen
let's say a 1 and then with high
probability this a 1 is always going to
be incoherent with all of the points
here so with high probability this will
be true and since we are only dropping
one sample so the new iterate and
true eateries are going to be very very
close to each other due to some
stability guarantee and as a result
since they are very close and one of
them is very incoherent with respect to
the sampling vector so we can say that
the entire sequence the true sequence is
also going to be very incoherent with
the sampling vector and it turns out
that this recipe can be very general so
let me briefly mention something about
matrix completion so I think probably
everybody knows what matrix completion
is essentially you have a low rank
matrix you observe partial entries about
this about this matrix and you want to
view in all the unseen entries and
usually we can look at the empirical
risk function like this and try to solve
this this non convex optimization
problems an existing theory starting
from Andreea so and then usually in in
crucem regularized loss function by
adding some penalty term to the original
empirical loss function all you can use
like well professor Wainwright has done
is say in for some extra projection
operation to enforce in coherence what
we can say is that none of these is
really necessary actually even practiced
and practically none of these is
necessary so what we are going to do is
basically just run the vanilla gradient
descent with spectra initialization and
then we can show that the very fast
convergence of this vanilla gradient
algorithms and what we can say is that
so if you look at their error terms the
convergence happens with not only with
respect to let's say that you credo Nome
now it also happens with respect to
let's say the spectral norm it also
happens with respect to the L to
infinity norm in this case which
actually is exactly how we define the
incoherence from the matrix completion
problem okay so a byproduct of all of
these analysis I actually can show that
in a noisy case if you
just run banana gradient descent we're
able to control the entry wise error in
an optimal way
so you achieved a minimal minimize about
in terms of the entry wise errors so the
errors are really spread out across all
of the entries no spectral for example
even the noiseless case spectral method
it doesn't have a zero error so you need
to refine in order to get zero error so
that's before converse or noncoms
optimization in this in the noisy case
you can always get any any level of any
resolution you want so this also extends
to other problems I blind the
convolution I don't have time to talk
about this
the final slice is this so the in
coherence region as I plot here it looks
like a Polito
but this is really an illustration in
the two-dimensional space you really do
need to think about in a high
dimensional world so your mental
representation probably should be sort
of like this hyperbolic drawing rather
than this poor little thing so which is
basically saying that the region
actually is vanishing this more compared
to the eligible even though this is
vanishingly small you can still make
sure that the entire iterate sequence
can stay within this dis dis Congress
concept ok so just to summarize this is
some nice thing about gradient descent
so even without any extra regularization
you achieve very fast computational
complexity a very very good
computational complexity and as a
byproduct we are able to obtain entry
wise error control for non converse
algorithms and the papers are kept thank
you
[Applause]
if you come say you're just optimizing a
quadratic for breakfast graded listen
very quickly it's for the worse so so
you look at the worst case so there is a
region where some of the point I mean
there's the region with like within the
l2 ball some of the points are very bad
so if you are so if you okay so so first
of all I would like to say that all of
these happen when you have spectral
initialization so with this particular
initialization method you're able to
make sure that even when they will you
start the algorithm your starting point
is also going to be in some region that
has nice geometry so you never hit the
bad region actually and then with high
probability with this initial guess you
can make sure that your follow-up
iterates will also stay within the nice
region rather than going to this this
bizarre region that has a bad geometry
relate to not really well it does relate
to some spectral property because you
want to make sure that at least there
are sufficiently many points at least
that so so okay so if you have infinite
samples you have infinite samples and
you need to make sure that they are some
sufficient equal spectral property there
in order to have a good convergence but
the tricky thing is that if you have a
finite samples and they do not
necessarily converge to the case at a
population level so you see a lot of
fluctuation there in the final sample
case and that is the part that you need
to deal with but but definitely we need
some spectral property there and even in
the infinite sample case
so could you separate for me which of
the results for which results you
actually need iit caption measurements
and for which you actually need only the
incoherence of imagine most of the okay
so this is a eyes so so so for matrix
complete for matrix completion what what
does it mean by ID goes in here actually
for face whichever one very suitable one
so far we only prove it for ID Gaussian
or ID sub Gaussian I don't think they
are there they're crucial I think if you
have like sort of like sub Gaussian rows
not necessary ideal sub garcia
measurements i think it should work but
just in coherent that will be tricky
because we need to use some so so let me
put it this way if you only have a
deterministic condition like only in
coherence probably this will not work
but if you let's say I give you a
dictionary
you know this dictionary is incoherent
but I randomly sample a few of them from
that maybe this will work
yeah but in general I don't think the
deterministic
[Applause]